Take your index finger and your thumb and
lightly grip the base of your tail and run
your fingers along the length of your tail.
You mean stroke it?
Nobody used that word. This is not a stroking motion.
This is a completely non-sexual thing I am
asking you to do.
In a completely non-sexual way.
Squeeze the base of the tail lightly with
your thumb and index finger, and then, while
continuing to squeeze, run them up the length
of your tail to the tip,
and I'll make you a clone.
I only have to do it once?
I'll tell you when to stop.
I don't know why you're stopping. Nobody told
you to stop.
Give me a little smile. Your lips look a
little dry.
Why don't you wet them a little bit?
My God, you're so weird!